hi my name is Hannes I'm here to talk to
you about web development in China I'm
doing web development since 2004 so
around I is six times if anyone
remembers this and I always did that
being in Hamburg but I got bored of
being in Hamburg and in Germany so in
2011 I ended up in China as a web
developer and that was not completely my
expression but it was a little bit my
expression so it's a screaming legal
person there because I felt like going
back into the past a little bit because
in 2011 when I arrived in China I had to
deal with supporting ie6 again this is a
world map of usage of ie6 in 2011 and
you see this red spot there
I assume this in a little bit this is
China with like over 30% so I was like
already used for not supporting i6m
anymore and then I was right back
supporting i6 so what was not so great
so in the last seven years all of this
changed by now everyone is using a
mobile phone pretty much all the time
and maybe like you feel more comfortable
booking a flight ticket on a desktop
computer or a laptop that's what I do
in China everyone does pretty much
everything besides work maybe the
majority does everything on a mobile
phone
so there's highly mobile optimized how
does this happen that people actually
skip computers so it's so-called a
leapfrog effect so people always had
like the majority of people always had
cell phones and the whole generation of
people basically skip from having a cell
phone over the desktop to like having a
computer in their hand having a
smartphone so a lot of people the
majority of people actually never had a
desktop at home they just have the
smartphone this is why most people
always use a smartphone by now before I
go into my talk I want to give you an
overview of what I'm going to talk about
I talk about three topics I call this
the mandatory part I talk about if you
do projects for people within China for
users within China what you need to take
care of I talked about the important
part WeChat it's the number one social
media app in China and I talked about
the
development ecosystem the community part
in China I think this is the most
interesting part before I actually talk
about these topics I would like to know
here in the audience who of you have
been to China okay not too many people
actually so for the people who have not
been to China no worries I'm gonna pick
you up there so you've heard that stuff
is blocked in China right Facebook
Twitter Google stuff is blocked but you
don't know what that actually means
because usually you come to a new
country you get out of a plane you flip
out your phone you ask Google how to get
your hotel well if you do that in China
this is how it looks like so you still
get the familiar blue spot but you don't
get anything else and Google will not
talk to you so and even though you
thought you'd be prepared you might
figure out okay maybe not that prepared
anymore other people come to China a
little bit more prepared like Mark
Zuckerberg he runs over Tiananmen Square
in Beijing and still kind of somehow is
able to post it on Facebook so other
people come to China a bit better
prepared and now that you have an idea
of how it feels to be like a tourist in
China I would like to talk about the
first topic the projects in China or the
projects for people in China or for
users in China so if your client tells
you hey what can we do so that people in
China can use our webpage well first of
all you might add translations to it
right so you have maybe web fonts on
that page and I had a client and they
said well we have all these print
products here and we have a special fund
for Chinese characters standing in the
way here having a phone for special
Chinese characters that we use for
printing products maybe we can like
transform that file and you can use it
on the Internet and I said yes sure
that's a great idea send it over and I
send over a file and was 50 megabyte and
I was like maybe not a good idea because
Chinese has a lot of characters
obviously and so they said put it in
anyway maybe not so the idea is just use
system fonts if you use Chinese on your
web page if you want to use a web phone
make sure that it's really highly
optimized another thing that people like
to do is having maps on the page to show
fancy things and usually they use Google
Maps to integrate
and you have like this is our company
and we have branches all over the world
this is how it looks and China looks
like this so you don't see anything
right so if you want to make sure that
you have a map and the Chinese users the
Chinese audience also can see it you
might want to use alternatives to Google
Maps for example Network still works
anyone from netbooks in here nope okay
and maybe the better alternative is
using a Chinese provider in this case
it's Baidu Maps this works reliable
within China
you just have to pedal the Chinese
translation but I'm sure you can copy
and paste code it's going to work
um payment maybe you paste of sorry you
sell stuff on your web page and you
wonder why is none of the Chinese users
now that we translated everything is
buying stuff on my page well that's
because you offer all these Western
payment kind of ways that are not
popular and China pretty much at all
nobody is using these maybe some but
obviously not the majority so what do
they use well in the real life you find
these signs and restaurants and shops
online everywhere you find these three
payment methods here so if you want to
make sure that people from China are not
hesitant to buy stuff on your page you
want to integrate at one at least one of
these payment methods on your page um
it's not that bad if you already use a
payment integration service like stripe
a wire card they usually already offer
at least one of these payment methods
that you can then easily integrate in
general is something nope okay in
general it's always like a good idea to
host stuff yourself if you use CDN
content delivery networks or web phone
providers make sure these are not
blocked in China and also make sure that
these make that show on a regular basis
because we will never know when stuff is
changing so maybe the better idea is
just to host up in general on your own
server and then you think like how can
we improve performance now that we have
done all this well you can host in China
right it's gonna be faster to load for
the Chinese users hmm well in China
hosting is a little bit different maybe
I've seen a Chinese web page to have
these small numbers down here I assume
that's in a little bit
it says ICP up maybe you cannot read it
so good it says ICP
there's a number ICP stands for Internet
content provider and it's basically
somehow the number plate of your webpage
so it indicates who's responsible for
the content of your web page and yes if
there's any issue for example that
happened to other people that I know you
have a country selector and you list all
the countries in the world including
Hong Kong and Taiwan someone's going to
call you and say please change that
otherwise we're gonna block your page
how to get this Internet content
providing number well you need a company
in China so you need an entity of a
company in China or corporation partner
or someone that helps you with applying
to this doing this process of applying
for an ICP number and once you have done
that takes a longer time maybe up to six
eight weeks then you can legally host in
China and that was my first topic
already that was talked about don't use
web fonts for Chinese unlike unless
they're really optimized don't use
Google Maps offer Chinese payment
methods host of yourself and if you want
to host in China get a license for that
um next topic I want to talk about is we
said maybe you've heard of widget
maybe people told you it's like the
what's app of China and yes maybe that
was the case some years ago but by now
that pretty much changed so in the
Western world we use all these different
apps here to do all kinds of things on
our mobile devices by now you could say
the majority of these things all these
things can be done in China by only
using beachhead which at is created by a
company called $0.10 and it's pretty
much integrated into Chinese society by
now how it is integrated into your daily
life I would like to show that in some
real-life examples here here there's a
QR code in a restaurant I open which
that I scan the QR code and I can order
food and I can pay and it can deliver it
to my table I ordered coffee here with
me Chet yeah these are like QR codes
that you see everywhere in restaurants
that you use for scanning and payment
this is me
doing this scanning one of these QR
codes and then paying with read shed you
can also use that for street vendors
selling foods or other things on the
street they're gonna show you a QR code
and you can pay with WeChat basically
most of the Chinese people or maybe just
yeah yeah most of Chinese people they
don't take cash anymore they just need
their phone and you go out and you can
do everything with your phone you can
also rent bikes with it maybe you've
seen these bikes also in Berlin and you
know that you have they already have
their their own native apps to rent a
bike here right but these are also these
functionalities are also integrated into
a WeChat so once you have reached it and
you can rent all these bikes you don't
need the native app anymore
you can also do hospital appointments
with WeChat and the last thing that I
figured out apparently you can get a
divorce with wheat shed so yeah you can
do a lot of things where we chat and
yeah so give you an idea of how this
looks inside of reach that apart from
the chat application I want to introduce
you the wallet and how it looks like for
example here you have a mobile top-up
thingy if you run out of data on your
phone you can just top up your data plan
there there is something called
utilities if you click that you get an
overview its Chinese here but it's an
overview of your utility bills like
electricity water etc you can pay all
this with WeChat and there's another
thing it's like third-party operators
these are being this is a default that
comes with WeChat you can by rail and
flight tickets order a cab get movie
tickets buy food etc etc and usually all
these services have their own native
apps but once you can use this why would
you install the native app right so when
we talk about mobile first I talked to
some Chinese development friends and
they said well and we didn't reach it in
China you could talk about which at
first because you need to make sure that
your stuff is not working on the Safari
browser you have to make sure that your
stuff is working in side of widget
and you can also extend that
functionality and before this was done
by creating html5 pages that will be
opened in the internal browser of
Richard and you can use an SDK and do
payment and do the QR code scanning and
stuff but I think I don't know one and a
half years or one year ago they created
something called $0.10 created something
called which had many programs and
WeChat many programs are basically a
better extension of of a better way to
extend to each set and write your own
stuff for WeChat and I'll give you an
example here the example is the Chinese
Yelp it's called DNP and this is the
chat overview of WeChat and I'm asking
someone for a recommendation for a
Beijing duck read strong in Beijing and
this person replies me with a link and I
get a preview of this and usually you
would expect I click this and the
internal browser opens and shows me the
detailed information of the restaurant
in this case it doesn't do that because
it says here on the bottom you cannot
see that it says here it says mini
program so if I click this not the
internal browser opens but a loading
layer opens for like a second and then I
get the information of the Beijing duck
restaurant it's a good duck restaurant
and once you've done that and you
install these mini program into WeChat
you can also place that here on the
right on your home screen and if you
click it here you get the full
functionality of the Chinese Yelp Thien
Tinh in this mini program that is opened
in a WeChat layer and yes the anping has
his own third-party app but as I said
once you can do the majority of things
with just a mini program why would you
install the native app or why would you
go to the mobile site because you're
using WeChat all the time anyway and you
might say now this reminds me of the PWA
and yes you're right because you can use
it offline you can edit on your home
screen and it's really highly
performance optimized and loads very
fast but in this case it's a little bit
special so I call it progressive WeChat
apps
by exchanging the W and there's a little
bit special here because these things
are not hosted on your own servers these
many programs are hosted on the 10 cent
server those the company behind Reed
shed and they have servers all over the
world so it's gonna be delivered and
open very fast in which yet there's a
size limit initial size limit of 1
megabyte so it loads very very fast
there are some other restrictions but I
don't want to mention all of these now
and the most important thing I guess
it's not a hundred percent web
technology it's a combination of the
offer webview and native components from
each set like payment QR code scanning
and some other stuff yeah 10 cent how do
you create such a mini program 10 cent
decided to create their own JavaScript
framework and why not right why would
you do that
it's called we Lang and I said come in
we are closed because it's not open
source it's actually closed source and
yes it uses something called W XML WX is
s and JavaScript it's pretty much HTML
CSS and JavaScript they just called it
differently and as I said it compiles
into a native code a mix of native code
and the webview they also created their
own editor this is the preview this is
how you write code this is the debugging
looks like the chrome dev tools right
yes it's a modified version of the
chrome dev tools I would say at least
this is the code for a hello world it's
not big enough so I'm going to show you
two slides of code only so you know how
this we Lang will looks like so you're
not afraid of maybe using it so this is
the w XML pretty much just the HTML
template may be people say looks
familiar looks a bit like looks a bit
like UJ s and this is the CSS and this
is the JavaScript part there's just data
property and I add the hello world and
that's it and after you you load the
initial kind of JavaScript you can do
some other functionality like get user
information and stuff and stuff so you
see it's not like
at different they also have their own
bootstrap this is pretty much the
bootstrap of rich yet they provide some
UX elements that you can use to style it
in a way that it looks like we'd said
yes there was two Beach apart what did I
talk about I talked about we said the
number one social media app in China
there are other apps but this is the
most important at the moment at least I
introduced WeChat wallet and WeChat
payment and I introduced you the
progressive web apps of WeChat the mini
programs and this brings me to my last
part how many time do I have left like
10 minutes to have 10 minutes I have 2
minutes left
Wow okay this is the echo system part 4
minutes left okay cool this is the
interesting part the echo system the
community of China and when I came to
China in 2011 I was used to like go to
conferences go to meetups and exchanging
knowledge I had the feeling that was not
the case in 2011 I was there was not a
lot of conferences not a lot of meetups
and people stick to your own stick to
their own knowledge stuck to their own
knowledge to like keep their place safe
in a way by now this all changed they
have their own conferences javascript
view CSS react etc they have a lot of
meetups in the bigger cities and they
exchanged knowledge way more than before
and they also created their own
platforms because when we use Stack
Overflow we use English we feel
comfortable using English more or less
but for the majority there's obviously a
lot of Chinese developers they are
fluent in English but for the majorities
of Chinese developers I would say they
don't feel comfortable using English all
the time so they can still use this so
like search stuff and copy and paste
code as we all do but once you ask a
question here and not so ok in which you
can imagine how it works out and so they
created their own Stack Overflow it's
called segment fault it's green it's
green and it's in Chinese
and it's easier to use right if you're
Chinese um no but this is not the
biggest platform this just I wanted to
show this because of the name and the
similarities what they actually use is
not Quora but the core of China which is
Juhu
it's called Juhu and this is used to
exchange knowledge this is actually the
profile of Evan you the creator of UJS
because he's Chinese and he has accounts
on all the platforms not only Western
ones but also the Chinese ones and yes
they also created their own open-source
you have like big companies in China
creating a lot of open-source and now
all these open source usually and in the
Western world is being done in English
so if documentation issue handling
communications being done in English but
if you're they but the Chinese open
source is completely done in Chinese and
they have to cater for a specific
requirement so they have to be highly
mobile focused they really need to scale
because if your startup becomes
successful overnight and Germany maybe
add a half million users if your startup
becomes successful in China you can
easily add 50 million users overnight so
stuff needs to scale so and this is not
only interesting for developers in China
but also for developers outside of China
right so they want to use this as well
but now we notice that not only Chinese
have an issue with being comfortable in
English but there's obviously an issue
of us feeling comfortable in Chinese and
in these open-source projects these
issues appear can we have English please
or documentation and readme should be in
English because because because or even
better and this is not a native language
speaker la a native English speaker so
this is why he doesn't understand what
that actually means maybe but he says
guys please use English and I assume
this is a little bit because there's a
funny answer to this this answer says I
think it's the best time to start
learning Mandarin and yes maybe it is
maybe that's the solution we all learn
Mandarin till we figure out [ __ ] this is
hard maybe not the best option to do
that so what can we do well every of you
I quote him here you don't need to read
all this figure that out
everything you says the project one of
the project I just showed it says it
lacks in terms of documentation and
learning resources for English speakers
we intend to bridge this gap next year
and I think this is so important to
actually bridge that gap not only
Chinese English but like into all the
directions how do we do this well we
create and this is one is another choice
open source approach
we create dedicated tasks document
translation looking for volunteers who
can help out and I think this is so
important that we do this because it
doesn't only make it easier for people
from not speaking Chinese to use your
project or from people all over the
world developers all over to use your
project but I think these kind of tasks
are also a great way with a low entrance
barrier to participate in open source
because maybe you don't feel too
comfortable of like writing great
JavaScript but you speak two languages
and this is your first step into open
source you just can start helping to
translate stuff and then maybe slowly
getting into more of that so I think
this is a great thing and view is doing
this really great and views very popular
in China that maybe is because the
creators actually Chinese but also I
think view in general is doing a great
job on documentation and translations
and I actually read an article because
there is a huge react community in China
but I read an article from a Chinese who
actually created segment fault saying
there's a well there used to be at least
a big problem of channeling back
knowledge from the Chinese react
community to the American order to the
International because of this language
barrier and you don't have this in view
so I think if this continues we all just
gonna use view of soon because they do a
really great job on this no it's just a
joke so so view is very popular and I
think it's getting popular all over the
world but yeah I just want to say that
you really good job and translation
documentation and that was the last part
what did I talk about I talked about the
shift from not sharing knowledge to
actually sharing knowledge having
conferences having meetups creating
their own platforms to exchange and
sharing knowledge also WeChat is used
for that I talked about the language
barrier of both sides and I said talked
about how to enable developers by
providing and even more people by
providing dedicated translation to us
Wow and that's it thank you very much
I'm done
remember thing if you if you have any
feedback let me know
hi oh hi oh yo yo Wendy Mitch are
walking Leo Leo ha aces yeah
[Music]